divertimento in südafrika mit
globetrotter im spezialist für
maßgeschneiderte reise wald wie
globetrotter der punkt ch
die woche sind bei man und der johnny
vom kabarett direkt zusammen unterwegs
wo sie kilometer quer durch südafrika
und zur bewährungsprobe
täglich werden kann
[Musik]
london vor ganz südafrika
ich bin ich bin mega mega ganze crew und
die sparte bis mit den häufigsten
[Musik]
hast
diese liegen
das riesending besser als die sache wohl
ganz besonders viele tiere
der mann hat sich gewünscht dass strato
bischof der wald zu nach wie möglich zu
lernen
[Musik]
häufig bleibt ihnen am boden gemacht
das großes wirklich viereinhalb metern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
idee so genannte schock erlitten wie sie
herr jedem anderen den zieht aufgekauft
[Musik]
aber so nah zu konstituieren
aber hinter dem ohr den hof verwies die
haie gibt bald wird diese vom aussterben
bedroht es gibt nur maximal vierter sieg
für den tsv stolte vom hyde auch nicht
lizenziert und in bestimmten teil vor
der enormen zum schutz von visa
[Musik]
wie hoch sie in wunschzettel hat ein
punkt weniger
[Musik]
das
schade
ich tun
und nun
wieder mal
jamann
mehr
lehrer und davos
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit festem boden unter dem gurt kreisel
der monotonie wand steht honor wird bald
oder zumindest der chor genannt
[Musik]
letztlich sind die zwei vor kapstadt
hermanus vor
jetzt waren sie total bestieg ubisoft
marius kloppers mit stick winters
[Musik]
als der opel ag
und die braucht
heutige tag ist sie ist kap agulhas der
südlichste punkt vor afrika
jsl wiz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bild ist heute stewart als highlight
sondern und jetzt am schluss hatte ich
am ersten drei minuten takt
sonnenuntergang wie die afrika jetzt
noch nicht oder zwei den klassischen
gegangen jetzt wieder vertragen ich
verrecke mit dem südlichsten punkt für
die landespolitik
mit aufgekauften johnnys in die zweite
heimat
auf dem motto zeige mir das land zu
gehen hat
[Musik]
trägt man
im fahrzeug
glücklich und sonst viel niedriger
freien tag
zwischen mekka
emotions erfüllt
wie also eine sitzung mit dem grafik
natur bombastisches das berührt ein und
aus ich bin mega crash dem motto wissen
immer noch nicht so ganz
das ist
ich achte klasse des
wenn jedermann vorstellen
das ich
[Musik]
die unterkunft
doch der tanz das mal nur 100 meter vom
strand lag
[Musik]
das ist der südlichste punkt von afrika
dort traf der indisch und der
atlantische ozean offenen unterricht ist
ganz klar die fusion ist afrika cup in
davos wurde letzte 104 kilometer später
in der antarktis der johnny hat schon
immer mal oskar beck alias welle und der
wunsch auf sicht paket lässt geschrieben
ich muss treffen
nach der diskussion dass ich auf der
liste das ist mir wichtig heute
vorstellen kopf kommen ja diese
vorstellung bekommen
aber ich muss sagen ich habe es nie
das ist jetzt mit dem markt haben eine
schön und jetzt dort vorstellig
doch mit zwei indische und atlantische
ozean zusammen
das südlichste punkt vor den riesigen
kontinent aufgekommen dass schönes
gefühl
[Musik]
minute
die letzte jahrhundert sich der trend
des evd am kap agulhas gestrandet 140
rockliga der gerüchte
doch nur noch ein klugscheißer dass das
noch grüße schaftliche internetaktion st
das ist dass das wachstum bleibt oft
mitbürger ins mekka unterschlupf bietet
für fische werden
meeresbewohner und da nicht hin dass ich
mich gar nicht umwelt verschmutzt will
mehr stoff 16 aber glaub ich nicht wieso
ich meine chance und dann natürlich im
garten im winter des schiffes
[Musik]
von jonny und ohligs gut 300 kilometer
vor meerbeke bischof
[Musik]
17 uhr schwarze wo die 230 der
wickelfront
im alltag also folglich schweizer
kabarett wo ist der druck und die
gemeinsam mit sieht klopp
[Musik]
also wenn du stattfindet finden
und das ist logisch wie der bezirk ich
rede immer wieder angeschoben so
bettermann ich habe wirklich erstaunt
und ich glaube vor allem dass die reis
vor allem jeden ob ich lustig sind
der druck dass man jeden original cisco
zwei stunden mit unterhalten und für das
ist unfassbar wie mit einem total
entspannt sind wir sind nur noch
zusammen abend über glauben und zu spät
und die wenige druck probiert lassen was
nicht
das waren weise
oder draußen
[Musik]
unisex schon betrachtung klinik
behandelt sexshops wenig dass dieser
baum spielzüge darauf ist
[Musik]
ronny sexshop das ist es wirklichkeit
wurde nicht stimmt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist ein langer tag sie und dann erst
wird in kürze vor dem monster motto
unter tony nominiert
auf dem programm steht sie nicht mehr
zwangspensioniert gehabt also was ist
für liebhaber klassischer safari outfit
erschien
was natürlich kein fließband
hey
[Musik]
von g
ich muss sagen motivation für köhler
vielleicht nicht unbedingt mit erdling
safari aber ich bin offen für alles das
logo marisa
[Musik]
und entscheidet sich knapp fiel kraus
so erhält man die safari braucht man das
fernglas und geduld viel geduld nach
zwei stunden worte ich es so weit
ich habe mich aus der leaf sind ja aber
das war nicht so früh ausgang
dann würde gern weiter das sehen sie ja
aber es kommt sehr gut an firma und das
wird jetzt so genannten vom sofa kdh
durchaus große über bank kaufen
und genau wie ihr mann lieber die
bekanntlich verringern
[Musik]
gedanklich nur jung uns nächste ziel des
golfs war zwerge toll für die cdu schon
die nächste maschine völlig und demong
hat damit zu tun
[Musik]
ja ja ja ja und nein
[Applaus]
ja genau
[Musik]
welcome to the jungle ganzen welt
es ist toll dass tatsächlich
[Musik]
er hatte machen lassen und ihnen aber
die währungsrelationen bewegen
[Musik]
staubige straße 27
the backdrop des wartberg boss ist
südafrikanisches nationaldenkmal
[Musik]
johnny ist am kampf noch gewisse und nur
noch was wissen wir eigentlich gehen im
bett zwischen abschicken
tunebite first jetzt schon federn also
die umgehung
[Musik]
genau das hatte schon in niedrigen ist
jetzt die ganze nacht durch cacau nur
was unsere und jetzt betriebsrat
markram gegen das klischee das wohl
machen das haus und eingeschneiten
unbedingt zeigen dass die armee geht wer
sport macht und nicht mehr als gott den
gewinn annegret hahn und uns gerechnet
denn willst du siehst ja
[Musik]
große flüssigkeitsverlust dann ist die
das netz nichts erlaubnis aber wie
gesagt grenze war definitiv die letzten
20 minuten zweite
dass ich das höre sich 583
[Musik]
ruft wort wird sie städte turnier
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
b
perfekt
[Musik]
vielleicht sprachlos das letzte mal in
natura turin erstmals einen pass ist
karg und netz und da dass das buck grüne
oase am wasser entlang vor augen aber
glück und hat seine samenbank wird über
vier spielen sich das ist also wohl
gelegt so dass natürlich läuft das
ursprüngliche natur und man begann
geriet und dort mit dem rad fahren das
ja noch speziell das ist sehr wohl schon
gewählt
jetzt heißt es nicht dass armut vor
das ist das aber hätte dafür die natur
ist
so
[Musik]
beschäftigte die jetzt sagen ob ich
morgen ist wieder gut
[Musik]
gorbi konterte mono im hotel altes rad
bergbau sei der johnnie guitar
williamson
[Musik]
ich hoffe ich nicht einschlafen
ein taxi rufen
[Musik]
schluss
heja ich weiß nicht wie fit ich erfahren
und wildnis planung grenze nicht
durchschritten ist
naja also wieder geholt ich weiß dass
ich wenn wir unterwegs sind aber ich
weiß jetzt noch zwei hauptamtlichen ram
power mit das programm macht ein punkt
gerade johnny vorgestellt eigentlich
also
[Musik]
hormone und im juni liegt 200 kilometer
straße
fabians klopp
in zahlen
nach der gedanke stetig und nummern und
wie bitte
für libyens auf
ich habe dort arno tourist guide sowie
fußtritten
ich schäme mich
[Musik]
sie blüht
jeden ersten zwei dinge gibt später
entlassen os richtung
[Musik]
sondernummer wandel werke und ruhe am
ball wir ins klo
fabians klopp sind so schlecht dass man
mit 4
dort liefert und
[Musik]
wohin mit dem campingplatz war kraft
eine foto speziell stehen lockt
[Musik]
ok
patrick strauß und operieren und
hinterließ vor freud 100 fiel mit dem
abschnitt schmerzen gestöhnt durchs
wunderschöne gebiet wirklich
wunderschöne und im auto und es gibt ein
spalt die dunklen ritter südafrika
besser bekannt als relief program
aber dass ich kaum
o
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt ganz vermutlich recht und
das ist nicht optisch finden ist
megaschön und 1 80 aber ich würde sagen
[Musik]
das kannst du kommst wirst ernährung
liegt die region zu sprechen
[Musik]
was mir jetzt steht eben folgt auf der
ich das lied ist logisch wenn ich es mir
vorgestellt habe das kabinett die pläne
mit excel oder schlafen und luftkammer
lagerführung in die wir so nicht mehr
vorstellen aber das ist mittlerweile
sind die beide seit fast zwei wochen
unterwegs
ich bin was ist auf der reise verbindet
oder neue verbindet das haben wir bieten
ihm so viel wie männer kommen da
unterwegs zweimal an der laaber
inspirations erleben und vor allem beide
mit dem kühl im buch im herzen kopf
nicht nur lustig sie jetzt ich habe das
ganz wichtige erfahrung die mir immer
wieder zusammen und machen und jetzt aus
aus freunden will so stich acht bisschen
zu starten kollege mit mit waffen die
sie in der woche fünfmal zum teil
scharfe mit mega viel druck und das ist
eine unheimliche unterschied aus am
arsch der welt in eine felsspalte
karriere und dass das ist so verbinden
[Musik]
am 8
wendig und es meistens gleich gegen den
akku russe zerlegen umgekehrt wie vor
dem anblick begeisterung sie aber das
ganze hat dann ein langweiliges ende
gefunden mit einer schlaflosen nacht
gruß kulisse und an das schnarchen die
kollegen schlechten schlaf gefunden
[Musik]
witzels richtig gelegen mitten vier mal
fiel durch wildnis von der bahn wie hans
klok das weckte floßlände mit kaputter
bühne sind support schwach der alltag
aber hinter dem duo im geschäftsfeld es
dann noch viel schreiben wird offenbar
ist das du bist du hübsch und jetzt wird
es ganz richtig schlimm der ware
[Musik]
aber als ich bezogenen und das ist das
ist eben das oxid das blieb so manches
herz auf einem riesen
[Musik]
nein ich glaube das darf
[Applaus]
durch dick und dünn wird in der woche
dort mit der leistung südafrika
[Musik]
divertimento in südafrika mit
globetrotter m spezialist für
maßgeschneiderte reise wald wie
globetrotter der punkt ch